theater tour absolutely crushing in
these theaters stronger than ever this
is a brand new minute sing it if you
know the
words
[Music]
everybody thank you in support of Israel
I've been going to restaurants and not
tipping it also doubles a support for
black lives
matter horrible to hear what's happening
over there in Israel Palestinians are
being murdered they're being bombed it's
a real Holocaust over
there a lot of Israelis were killed at a
music festival which is horrible but but
why are you having a music festival
right next to
Gaza who are these people like man The
Vibes at the next to this open air
prison are bumping
man call me a [__] but I refuse to
party a paraglide away from a bunch of
hungry thirsty
[Music]
Arabs all right thank you H Kim ladies
and gentlemen using his Asian race to be
able to offend many other races you're
very racist thank you you can get away
with it
you got the Jews the blacks and the
Arabs all in 55 seconds there how do you
feel Hans I feel great I have offended
some of the most dangerous people in the
world
yeah I just have to rely on my skills
from the LA riots that I learned uh you
did offend some of the most dangerous
people in the world also the Arabs and
the Jews you also offended during that
seconds I love it Hans what else is
going on I had an amazing time in Ohio
and Youngstown the birthplace of kill
Tony in some ways absolutely um I met
your brother he tried to put his balls
in my drink really I didn't even know
about this yeah it was a it was a
hilarious
moment everyone got to laugh at me uh
pull his balls out this was Donnie yeah
Donnie California he was pretending to
do it he was pretending to do it I was I
was freaking out a little bit he didn't
pull his actual balls up no he wouldn't
do that he's a gentleman he is and uh
you got to meet my elusive father we
went to his house and he cooked us a
gigantic Italian meal oh it was so good
I anything stand out to you from that it
was like the uh an episode of The
Sopranos
um he did have books on Italian cooking
and only organized crime those were the
two things I was surprised to see uh
what else Hans llat uh she's a good
friend of mine and uh we just were up to
no good just [__] ribbing each other
and you know she's calling me Asian I'm
calling her fat yep you Liz Splat and
cam Patterson Young rabble rousers of
the comedy scene and we had a lot of fun
together three soldout theaters packed
to the gills Cincinnati Philadelphia and
Youngstown what stood out to you
anything else uh Cincinnati was great I
took a shower in Cincinnati and my hair
has never been the same since what
happened it is voluminous I don't know
man it's great thank you little H Yeah
Yeah Lil hobo what' you think of Han's
set I don't know I wasn't really paying
attention
what were you thinking about the
apocalypse
hey little hope well it is the end of
the world I mean we all kind of know
that inside our hearts right
Tony I do agree yeah it's
[Laughter]
true I love it Hans not even getting
little Hobo's attention all the way well
hobo what are your thoughts on the Jews
and the Arabs and the blacks on the Jews
and the Arabs and the blacks well I mean
I I think we're all just the same thing
essentially you know I don't see color
or race or religion I just see Souls I
see Souls that will all be consumed by
my father Lucifer at the end of
days yeah I
understand Jesus
Christ little hobo really flexing really
flexing D Madness also if you guys
missed it said he also doesn't see color
every
body or race or anything at all for that
matter uh Hans I love it you're a
[__] stud you came out again topical
material covered it being extra racist
because you can be but you got the show
started you do it every week it's
[__] unbelievable great great great
shows on the uh theater tour this week
[__] amazing you're so consistant uh
if anybody doesn't hasn't before and you
see Hans Kim on the road near you trust
me go watch him headline he's a [__]
rock solid comedian I know these guys
watch you do a minute every week and
they've watched you do it for years and
it is so hard to do that if anybody
doesn't think it's hard I challenge you
to [__] try it once a week and uh run
it by a friend and watch yourself bomb
in front of one person and uh but we
love you Hans thank you Tony Tacoma
Spokan you Tacoma Spokan hans.com
Regular
Show H kim.com everybody for tickets
that was Hans Kim that was Hans Kim I
pull another name out of the bucket we
get that comedian and the comedian that
I pulled first